après on n'est pas à l'abri d'une bonne
nouvelle mais pour l'instant à dont
l'étoile abri dont les non mais
sérieusement enfin je veux dire c'est
assez désagréable parce que en réalité
on a tous aussi on est content on
s'enlise en les planches rigoles ou quoi
être qu'on sort des croûtons de quoi par
exemple de quoi juste écouter suspect de
débâcher d'échangés content vous ne
voulez pas venir du coup de couteau mais
les signalements de paul est content on
a au sort dont elle est extrêmement
compliqué oui ça a été très compliqué on
est en train de sortir on en train de
réouvrir il faut le faire de façon
progressive et de façon extrêmement
vigilante pour ne pas justement avoir
une quatrième bague quoi il faut être
content le rap est arrêté pendant les
vous avez répondu à ma question est
comment ça il faut bien content du fait
qu'on est en train de sortir oui mais
attendez il ya deux payés vous même qui
s'entraîne en fait c'est une histoire du
mec qui sait faire arrêter par erreur
qui est foutue récuser vous savez
création sortir quoi même en compte
présentement vous oubliez vous oublié
quelque chose dans moult ya quelque
chose oui j'oubliais quelque chose c'est
dommage mais on voulait quelque chose
c'est que la situation sanitaire a été
extrêmement compliqué je vous voulez
peut-être pas parler des malades
peut-être pas des décès mais pensez
aussi aux soignants qui souffle l'homme
et en ont marre de travailler qu'ils
peuvent mieux encore aujourd'hui leur
bail et mayer d'autant plus heureux
alors presque prévenir pour une fois et
qui continuent aussi à se mobiliser sur
les campagnes de vaccination sont donc
je pose une ce pour ça il faudrait un
tout petit peu de respect et d'humilité
et les soignants c'est ce qui vous avait
distribué des masques ffp2 quand il y en
avait que vous avez rappelé parce qu'ils
sont contaminés premiers éléments dont
vous mettez en danger et soignants et ça
moi vous donner des leçons des soignants
c'est moi qui les ai défendu pour voir
les masques que vous leur avez refusé
sous affluents
vous êtes bien aimable mais le premier
procès qui a été fait dans son cri c'est
moi qui les fais parce que vous ne
vouliez pas donné de masques de
protection soignants alors venez pas
avec moi aujourd'hui sur ce plateau me
parler des soies games est méprisé
durant un an que vous avez piétiné
durant un an vous ne vous avez qu à nous
excuser moi excusez moi je terminais mon
tour que vous avez tellement contaminés
par ce que vous avez envoyé à la guerre
paraît-il sans masque sans protection
avec eux pendant que les ministres se
faisait tester les soignants n'ai pas
accès pendant que les députés avaient
des masques les soignants n'ai pas accès
alors de grâce de grâce n'essayez pas
avec moi de jouer ce jeu là ça
risquerait de m'énerver vous avais
aucune envie je m'énerve
12e point non vous allez au coude
poignet pour la deuxième point je
termine sur ce point les malades madame
les malheurs c'est ce qu'ils ne peuvent
pas trouver que les réanimations que
vous avez fermé que vos prédécesseurs
ont fermé c'est ça la vérité la vérité
c'est que nous sommes devenus des états
du tiers-monde par votre faute
alors venez pas aujourd'hui mettre sur
mon dos les boas capacités ce n'est pas
mettre sur mon dos je n'ai pas joué mais
en tout j'avais déjà non non et c'est là
que vous demandez aux dires
effectivement si vous ne voulez pas
penser aux malades avec gauzère
littéraire excusez moi madame et les
malades j'y pense peut-être plus que
vous est ce que vous faites aujourd'hui
en excuses en l'occurrence les soignants
c'est des malades j'y pense et soignez
vous n'avez jamais pensé et les malades
il fallait y penser au moment où vous
avez fermé les lits de réanimation
vous avez fermé des lits de réanimation
entre mars et aujourd'hui vous avez
ouvert des lits de réanimation éphémère
1,7 et rien dans le réfectoire pour ne
pas ouvrir des différentes nations et
permanent à brice reprend peut-on sauver
non mais c'est ok vous foutent de moi
quand même mais la télé vous